all right well it had been a couple of
years as we move on since the last
Festival related
um disaster so we're due for another one
and uh burning man has stepped up to the
plate to deliver Burning Man is the
festival out in the Nevada desert or a
bunch of hippies and Tech Bros gather
together to do drugs and have sex and
not shower and smell each other's body
odor for four days a lot of pagan
symbolism and various rituals and it's
all very satanic and bad and gross but
this time the Satanic rituals went awry
because it rained and there's a lot of
mud and people couldn't leave they
couldn't get out because the the roads
weren't usable so they were stranded for
several days without proper facilities
without you know bathrooms the bathrooms
were overflowing it's all very
disgusting which meant that the very
gross event
was even grosser than usual but this is
the internet age which means that every
event has to spawn eight or nine
different conspiracy theories because
everyone feels like everyone thinks
they're living in a movie all the time
because there's a despair of their own
lives and you know they find their own
lives so dull and uninteresting so they
want to pretend that they're living in a
movie
and that's what happened this time
um you know as this is all unfolding
over the weekend with burning man you
have all of these people posting on
social media on Twitter on Tick Tock
saying what's really going on what's
really going on there there's there's
something going on
uh so here's just one example this is a
citizen journalist I suppose on Tick
Tock uh revealing some of the Sinister
uh Secrets at uh at Burning Man let's
watch this
most of y'all have probably heard that
Burning Man was declared a national
emergency but there's some pretty crazy
stuff coming out
so it was announced earlier that Burning
Man was declared a National Emergency
because it was flooded and so they sent
in FEMA which already seemed kind of
like a weird reason to send in FEMA and
keep anyone from leaving the festival 73
000 people they're keeping locked in
there for flooding
now there's some new terrifying
information coming out that there's a
virus on the loose in the festival and
that people are getting really sick with
boils vomiting hemorrhaging to me this
makes way more sense than flooding in
terms of what their response was to the
situation this is a text from one of the
festival goers and he said yo just
figured you should hear from me first
Daryl is crazy sick with something that
has him coughing up really coagulated
blood medic showed up wearing a full
suit no idea where he is now I would
stay inside your camper and he goes on
to say that an outside agency is putting
up a fence this is a different Festival
goer that said you're never gonna
believe it they're saying it's Ebola
freaking Ebola at Burning Man guys if
this is true that is insane I just hope
that everyone ends up being okay and
that they make it out
uh it's not true first of all so it's a
yeah that's my favorite Tick Tock video
which is a bunch of nonsense this is
true there's something going yeah it's
not true
um you know what's going on here
something oh you flooding you're telling
me they couldn't leave because of
flooding that doesn't make it why
doesn't that make any sense but it makes
perfect sense it rained like there's
flooding what do you want it's it's uh
that's it
for most homeowners a window replacement
isn't something they've done before and
for many it's not something that they
want to do but rather something they
have to do if you've put off replacing
windows in your home because it's too
expensive I have great news for you you
can now get a free in-home window
consultation and free price quote from
Renewal by Anderson Renewal by
Anderson's signature service is
committed to giving you the best
customer experience possible through the
perfect combination of the best people
in the industry a superior process and
an exclusive product right now Renewal
by Anderson is offering a free in-home
or virtual consultation on durable
quality affordable windows or patio
doors for zero dollars down zero
payments and zero interest for a year
tax Walsh to 200 300 for your free
consultation to save 375 off every
window and 750 off every door these
savings won't last long so be sure to
check it out by texting Walsh to 200 300
that's Walsh to 200 300. so there's no
conspiracy here's what happened it's
exactly what I already said a bunch of
hippies and Tech Bros with no survival
skills went to the middle of the desert
to have sex with each other and use
drugs and they got it together on a
dried up lake bed
and then it rained okay and the ground
didn't absorb the moisture very well
because it's the desert so it's like
raining on concrete plus they're on a
lake bed okay they're on a lake bed so
the water pools and it creates a lot of
mud and then you can't drive your
vehicles and your hippie RVs and all
that on it and you have to wait for the
mud to dry up and uh and that's it
that's that's all that's all you need
for people getting sick yeah probably 95
of the attendees already had chlamydia
before they showed up so they're all
bringing it's like a potluck of viruses
at Burning men they're all bringing
their own viruses with them to begin
with okay they're all a bunch of
disease-infested disgusting people and
then they come together if you're pardon
the expression and they're there and all
the diseases are being spread around so
again we don't need any kind of it's a
petri dish of disease
were there people vomiting yeah probably
okay I want to vomit just thinking about
burning man I can't actually actually
being there
so
there's an important lesson here and by
the way the latest update is that
everyone's going home now so the the mud
dried up enough and now they're all
leaving and then they're not okay the
government's not there rounding them all
up and uh and sending them off to FEMA
camps
which I you know
you can make an argument that maybe we
should do that anyway you know I if we
were to round up everybody at at Burning
Man and send them to FEMA camps
like I mean just there's already as I
said there's a lot of probably
contagious disease already there and so
but anyway
um that's not happening so
I think an important lesson here
uh and the first one is don't go to
Burning Man Okay in general like don't
go out into the Wilderness unless you're
well prepared and have survival skills
and certainly don't go out into the
Wilderness with a bunch of sex-crazed
druggies that's the worst thing you can
do
um so that's the first lesson
and the second lesson is that you know
you shouldn't hatch conspiracy theories
unless a conspiracy is needed in order
to explain something
and sometimes it is so sometimes you
have something going on it doesn't make
sense and they're telling us something
and it doesn't add up and so and and
then you need to you need to introduce
speculatively an element of conspiracy
um in order to make sense of what you're
seeing and that's where and that's where
conspiracy theories can be legitimate at
the very least they can be defensible
um
but then you have the other kind which
is like what came with the Burning Man
which we don't need any you don't need
any kind of conspiracy theory to explain
this it's all very simple to understand
it all makes a lot of sense actually
uh and yet we introduce it anyway
because
you know
we want to make a
we want to make it more interesting
although look it would be an interesting
film plot like a a zombie virus uh
breakout as Burning Man
great at movie idea somebody shouldn't
make that movie I will make that movie
and nobody does that's a great movie
idea not reality though unfortunately if
you'd like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
Walsh Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed